hey friends so I've got a treat for you
namely a drill that I have given to each
and every one of my beginner students in
the past year and something that I think
is one of the best drills I've ever come
up with are you ready for it check it
out this is
it odd right seems kind of simple but
there's a lot packed into this one that
I think is of help for absolutely
everybody who's getting started at POI
and even lots of people who already know
quite a bit of it
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of Po spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today I'm giving you what I think is
the most important beginner drill that
I've come up with in the past year
because I bet you anything it's going to
help you out with your spinning but
before we dive in I just want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys pyot Tera
light toys and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
awesome companies and the work they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non-b buus friend
of the channel Becca beckon thank you so
much for supporting my channel my work
and my mission all right so first up
let's talk about what the drill is and
then I will will tell you why it is so
important so first things first you need
to know how to do a butterfly both a
forwards as well as a reverse butterfly
and you need to be able to spin the poy
in together times same direction in wall
plane whether it is going clockwise or
counterclockwise uh I have tutorials on
how to get down the butterfly that I
will go ahead and link to down in the
description uh suffice to say though
this drill only works if you have all
four of those pieces so first things
first here we got to work on figuring
out how to do a pendulum with just one
hand while the PO in the other hand
keeps on moving this in and of itself
can be a little bit of a challenge so if
we start off with our butterfly here
what I want you to do is I want you to
single out the right hand and think that
it's going to perform a pendulum going
out to your right hand side what this
means is that you're going to kind of
take away the momentum of it as it's
going around and let it point out and
then just stop now that in and of itself
is not that challenging but doing it
while you keep the left hand moving can
be so here's how I recommend you do that
probably what's going to happen the
first few times that you do this is
either you're going to find that the PO
just keeps going around your right hand
or you wind up doing a pendulum with
both hands so what I'm going to
recommend is you tilt in the direction
of Performing the pendulum with both
hands and then you actively think I'm
going to keep the left hand spinning
making sure that it's still going around
clockwise try that a couple times
spinning the PO butterfly performing
those pendulums and then giving the left
hand po a little bit of a kick to keep
it going around there while the right
hand is just hanging out now once you
have that piece down you want to bring
the right hand back around spinning
clockwise just like the left hand so you
want to sweep it down past your ankles
and around back out to the side you
should wind up with both of the poi
spinning clockwise relative to you so to
see that sped up a little bit we start
off in a butterfly and I do a pendulum
with the right and as the right hand POI
is coming back down and around I just
bring it around with the left POI if
your timing on this works out properly
it should just be that the two poy sink
together perfectly like butter and now
it's probably a good idea to practice
doing the pendulum the other direction
with the right hand so again as the PO
you're spinning what I'm going to do is
perform a little pendulum going
underneath the left hand with my right
and I'm going to really focus on keeping
my left hand pois spinning still
clockwise so from both of them going
clockwise I'm going to let that right
hand do the pendulum under and really
really focus on keeping the left hand
going clockwise the whole time when that
gets to feel comfortable I can swing the
right hand back around over to the right
side and I return to my butterfly so Al
together with both of those pieces I do
my pendulum out to the right with my
right hand bring both of the poy around
clockwise and then I do the pendulum
under my left hand with my right and
swing it back around to get to a
butterfly question that might pop up as
you're doing this is when you're doing
that transition back from together same
clockwise to together opposites how do
you keep the POI from tangling as you do
that pendulum with your right hand
here's the answer stick your arms out a
few inches away from you and as you
perform the pendulum with the right hand
draw it in towards you so that it winds
up at about the same place as the elbow
of your left hand and that way the
pendulum cannot possibly run into your
left-and poy you bring them back
together when you come out in the
butterfly so again all together we do
pendulum to the right clockwise pendulum
to the left back to a butterfly pendulum
to the right clockwise pendulum left
butterfly this is a good first step but
it is not the last one sweet now we have
to learn how to do all of that on the
left side so we're going to go through
the same steps here we're going to
perform a butterfly with both of our
hands and you're going to work on
performing a pendulum with your left
hand out to your left side again you
might find it easier to think that
you're going to try and start off with
both of the POI doing pendulums at the
same time and then you give your right
hand just a little bit of a kick to keep
it spinning yeah we do our butterfly fly
pendulums out give the right hand a kick
just make sure that the left hand Poise
stops moving that's the biggest part of
this step all right now with the left po
stop moving you're going to bring it
back around into counterclockwise so
both of the pole you're spinning in the
same direction here and you're going to
go ahead and do that same thing where we
do the pendulum under the right hand and
bring it back around in a butterfly so
Al together then we do a pendulum out to
the left come around
counterclockwise pendulum under the
right and come back around in a
butterfly so with either hand now you
should be capable of doing a pendulum
out to its own side and then crossing
under to return back to that butterfly
out to its own
side and then a pendulum back under the
opposite hand to return to the butterfly
so this in and of itself is actually a
really really good drill to do but it
isn't the final form of this drill cuz
there's one more tweak we're going to do
all right so if we play around with
pendulums as I just was that is playing
around with a butterfly doing a pendulum
with the right to clockwise doing a
pendulum over to the left back to
Butterfly and then with the left hand
doing a pendulum off to the left to
counterclockwise and then back under the
right hand to get back to the butterfly
we're dealing with two different
directions of together same but only one
direction of the butterfly and there is
actually a way that we we can reorder
the pendulums in this in order to do a
reverse butterfly as well as a forwards
butterfly here's how we start off
exactly the same way I'm going to have
my butterfly going and I'm going to do a
pendulum with my right hand over to the
right side and return and together same
going clockwise now here's where I shake
things up just a little bit rather than
doing another pendulum with my right I'm
not going to do a pendulum with my left
off to the left hand side and as it
drops back around guess what I wind up
in a reverse butterfly pretty cool now
I'm going to do another pendulum with my
right going underneath the left and when
I come out of it I have both of the POI
spinning
counterclockwise next my left hand is
going to do a pendulum under my right to
come back around to a butterfly so just
for the record we have right hand do
pendulum to get us to clockwise left
hand does pendulum to get us to reverse
butterfly right hand does pendulum to
get to counterclockwise and left tandas
pendulum to butterfly in other words we
have
right
left right left and that takes us
through each and every possible
direction of these two different timing
and Direction modes pretty cool so
ideally you want to get to a point where
you can just go back and forth between
these pendulums and all these timing and
Direction modes pretty quickly or hang
out for a couple beats in between each
one just to show show that you have
control over each of these different
timing and Direction modes before making
the switch so obvious question then why
learn this kind of overly complicated
drill especially as a beginner so the
answer is this is going to make you way
more comfortable with performing
transitions in general and more to the
point it's also going to mean that you
get a lot of practice spinning the PO in
all of these different directions and in
all of these different timing directions
modes this is just going to make you
more comfortable with the movement of Po
in general it gives you more freedom of
movement both with your body as well as
the poy and I think we can all agree
that is a good thing and it has to be
said the students that have given this
exercise to have overwhelmingly come out
of it way more confident with their
ability to do transitions as well as
their ability to move with the poy I
think this is one of those moments where
it's not like a trick per se that you
learn but that doesn't mean that it's
not super useful so here's hoping that
it's useful to you did you enjoy this
drill did it help you out in getting
more control over your poy do you want
more like it well I've got good news for
you because there's an entire reward
level on my patreon that is nothing but
getting a lesson like this delivered to
your inbox every single week of the
month it's called the flow Circle and
it's designed to make you both more
confident as well as more comfortable
moving around with your poy you can go
check that out over at
patreon.com dfactor poy the first lesson
of this month is up already did you get
anything out of this video if so please
make sure to like comment share and
subscribe to help other people find the
video and of course to help my channel
grow this video would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on patre
on in particular I'd love to give a
shout out to my flow patrons who are
listed on screen right now thank you so
much you all rock and if you out there
watching are not currently a patreon
supporter but you'd like to become one
you can do that by checking out my
patreon over at patreon.com dfactor Po
and signing up there you can get access
to a whole host of awesome rewards but
even better than that you'll be helping
me out in my mission to bring po
spinning and flow Arts to the whole wide
world so go check that out please and
thank you and if you'd like to check out
some other beginner exercises that I've
done videos on I'll go ahead and link to
one of my favorites up here on screen as
well as down in the description thank
you so much for watching I hope that
this exercise helps you out with your
own flow make sure to get outside and
get some of that flow on today and I'll
see you with a new video real soon take
care now peace